this is this
is i'm gonna have to go get something to
eat
you're not you're not stuffed i'm i
can't eat this there's no meat in it and
you it takes too much to break it apart
and you don't have the tools and it's
you know the metro sexual map yeah um
[Laughter]
we'll take you to uh mcdonald's after
this
taco bell it's only [ __ ] that's open
somebody
said they've never seen somebody
complain about crab legs you're
definitely not from florida
i'm from florida i was born in florida i
consider myself a florida cracker
i i mean you know i'm sorry that i
you know i'm unbelievable unbelievable
unreal unreal can't believe this [ __ ]
which one of his ids do you need to see
for you to believe that he's from
florida
that's amazing all right next question
what's the next question they're really
all the same [ __ ] sorry just ask them
like
what was your biggest regret while doing
why you were doing fraud
what was my biggest throughout your
entire career what's the one thing that
if you take back
one thing what would it be other than
this podcast
i was gonna say wow see you know what
that's one of those that's a that's good
that's a well that's a loaded question
because think about it
what the the i know the correct answer
is there's sausage
yeah what is it yeah let me
the correct answer is you get a piece of
stuff i wish i'd never
committed fraud to begin with um
right in that the correct answer no i
want to hear the truth that's the answer
i mean if if it also says like was there
a specific person
or situation you regret doing i regret
doing
tom joe yeah is there a specific one
person or or or frau crime or
i don't know wife probably texted him
that looks serious
time to change the diaper everybody pray
for danny it's time to probably throw
he's probably going outside to throw up
bad crap
bad crab too man all gonna be throwing
up crabs great this crab is amazing the
sausage is fine oh my gosh
my nose is running oh that [ __ ] was too
spicy
it's all spice this is more sausage in
there if you want to try it
no sausage is really good is it hot no i
i just know i'm good i'm good this is
if this doesn't taste like it mixes well
with coffee
what doesn't mix well with coffee i've
never sat down for a nice cup of coffee
and
played a crab let's see ooh that's
refreshing
what would be biggest
okay i got i got one i got it all right
all right so
one i made people throwing money you
know i should
you know one of the problems when i was
in south carolina
and i'd applied for a bunch of loans and
one of the loan officers
actually like i was closing the loans
and one of the loan officers
left and went on vacation and then came
back and processed the loan
so the actuary from the actuary
the abstractor went down to public
records to check public records
but as loans were closing so she
actually caught several of the
several of those loans well
i had like we had like 1.3 million in
the bank and we'd take it out like 600
000 or something
the problem was i remember
she was saying she was going on vacation
but it wouldn't
slow down it wouldn't stop the process
no big deal where i'll put everything
through i'm like okay so we're still
going to close within
the next you know 30 days oh yeah no
problem no problem well she didn't
and i remember thinking it may be an
issue and right then i
like i was like i was like oh god what
if she doesn't i was like was she saying
she's going to
so i didn't you know i was questioning
it but she seemed
like i should have right then been like
yeah you know
i'll come back or i'll i should have but
i didn't
that was an issue that was an issue the
other issue was
the thing i did with with allison arnold
which was
where she pretty yeah i'm done thank you
where i
where uh she pretended to be rosita
perez
like that was so there was just no real
benefit
it was just alison saying she wanted to
do something
what could she do i had everything was
going smoothly without her doing that
and for some reason i was like
well you know you could do this it was
kind of like i was just trying new
things
to give her something to give her
something to do and it was stupid
i i could have given her you know i
could have just said look let me give
you ten grand
right go spend this right you can pay
you can pay me back later i'll get you
on your feet no big deal
but instead and i was giving her money i
did rent her a place and bought her
stuff
but i was like
i did it just because it was kind of a a
practice run to see what would happen
and this and that and really what i was
doing was working very smoothly
and was just pure stupidity it was like
trial and error
well that's not the kind of it's not the
kind of business you do trial and error
yeah
trial and error is somebody go gets
caught and goes to prison
and it just it was just a complete
disregard for
everything that i had already kind of
knew was and was bet
was wasn't going to work or shouldn't be
tried and i tried it anyway
because i was thinking i'm not going in
the bank so
worst case scenarios they get grabbed
i'll get him a lawyer well this well
that you know it was just it was just
stupid
yeah but you can't always trust people
in that situation oh no you can't trust
anybody
nobody i know didn't turn on me
immediately but i didn't know that at
the time
at the time i thought oh you know this
person won't say anything but that that
just wasn't the case
you know which is fine you know i don't
blame anybody
it was certainly it was absolutely my
fault like i never should have
involved allison arnold she and she
didn't even do anything she didn't even
know anything she was just
you know she was just at a bad spot and
i took advantage of the situation she
was there
yeah you know and she i should have
known i mean i i i should have known i
did know
and i did it anyway because i thought
well i wonder if this will work yeah
this should work yeah hey we could do
this and
what the [ __ ] am i doing i'm already
i've already got a full proof plan
that's making tons of money
we wanted more yeah well i was it wasn't
more it was just trial and error i
wonder if this will work now it's just
like hey
let's tweak it here let's do this let's
do this hey i wonder if this would work
you know it's like okay
what are you doing you're getting
[ __ ] creative you've got a foolproof
money making machine right here
don't get cute just stick with the plan
it's working
nobody the banks didn't even know they
were being defrauded
i'm buying a house for 50 or 40
recording the value
barring 150 160 walking away with a
hundred thousand dollars
then the house goes into foreclosure six
months later the banks take it
back they don't even realize that they
lent 150 or
100 000 more on a house they take it
back they sell it they take the loss
they think well we
we just lost a hundred thousand dollars
that happens sometimes
and that's what they were it was
happening for a year and a half they're
not even looking
they don't even realize it and then i
start getting cute
it was just that that was just pure
stupid i think that answers the question
pretty much just stupidity i've got lots
of stupid things i did
it hurts me when you ask questions like
that i would scream them better i didn't
you know i'm just reading these danny
prints them he picks these yeah
i got one keep that in mind from david
renee who
dropped five dollars in the crab bucket
thanks david the us government had
offered matt the chance to work for them
for 20 years minimum
non-negotiable in exchange for no prison
time would he have done it
i mean am i going to get paid i mean i
still have to get paid i still have to
live
that's one of those questions are you
setting terms for the us government i am
saying trump because
if they're like oh we're going to pay
you 24 000
a year for the next 20 years well i'm
not
i mean you'd rather just write it out in
jail i don't know i mean that's like
can i work a side job like am i i'm an
indentured [ __ ] uh servant for
the next 20 you know that's that's a
tough like or you go to jail for 10
years or you get 26 years or 20 you know
whatever it is
i need more but i would basically say if
the terms were correct
then yeah i would absolutely do that of
course good answer who wouldn't do that
you know that's the whole frank abagnale
thing
the catch me if you can like everybody
that watches the movie thinks that the
fbi got him out of prison
they didn't get him out of prison you
know he got out of prison on
if you read his book he actually got out
of prison on parole
he was denied i think the first and
second time he was up for parole i think
he did like six years total on a huge
sentence of like four
fourteen years or something i think it
was 14 years he ended up doing like five
or six years
he gets out and then he starts working
for the working teaching classes like it
doesn't happen the way
the way they portrayed it in the movie
he actually did all of his time
and people like oh yeah the fbi came in
they got him out no they didn't you all
watch the movie the movie's wrong read
his book
he tells the whole he tells exactly what
happens in his book which is called uh
the art of steal that's the second book
to
uh catch me if you can and he goes over
a whole bunch of scams and stuff too
it's actually pretty cool catch me if
you can the book is pretty cool
really it's almost the same the book is
that same title catch me
it's almost exactly like the uh like the
movie almost
there's some subtle differences we're
actually heading in a great direction
because we got another
question from sandro nilas who dropped
five bucks
what is the best fraud matt ever heard
about and is it still going on
also he needs an audio book version and
he wants you to read it
and audio read the audiobook you must
have just turned
tuned in uh i've got a professional
narrator
doing the audio version of your voice
yeah they don't want a professional
your voice it's like a real thing i
can't read it i read like a fourth
grader it would be horrible
and you wouldn't want to read it why
don't you do your audiobook the same way
david goggins did his audiobook he
didn't actually read from anything he
basically just did what we're doing he
had like uh
so he had like a professional story to
somebody that yeah david goggins did an
audio version of his written book
and he basically had a guy like who was
a professional like a professional story
guy who reads books basically ask him a
list of structured questions to where
goggins
could fill in the blanks talking from
the heart you know what i mean right so
it's kind of like a hybrid podcast slash
audiobook and it was actually really
entertaining i thought it was done
really well you should check it out
that would be a good option for you to
do i think people would love that
you could give me that i could ask you
the questions i'll send it to you
give me the link we can hang out yeah we
can eat crab and read your audiobook
there's more crab over here yeah you
want these crab intaters
i mean he's shoot he's chewing up the
bone i'm gonna let him go to waste
showing up the bone too i mean it's the
bone it's my first time eating crab
i gotta be careful no no no no no here
put it put it over here
let me throw this away don't waste it
don't waste the juice
hey who wants to see danny drink the
juice if anybody drops 10 bucks danny
he'll drink the juice
50 bucks he'll drink the juice i don't
think danny's drinking that juice i'll
drink it
i